summer heat is here in Dawn's corner is
sharing the essential items you must
have on your shopping list so let's
check it out
hello summer these are four of my top
companies that I want you to add to your
summer shopping list first up from
JCPenney comm it's your one stop shop
for any home fashion or accessory needs
they've got great budget-friendly prices
as we all know and again they've got
incredible values I'm loving their
private label Arizona swim shorts for
guys this year they come in great fun
colorful patterns their drink ware is
fun with all the flamingos on them
they've got great flip-flops they've got
wonderful name-brand classes by Liz
Claiborne we all need to keep our eyes
protected and what I really love too
about the JCPenney party platters is
they're great to bring to a party
they're so affordable and actually leave
as a gift for the hostess so it's kind
of my one place that you can go to I
even got this beautiful necklace that
I'm wearing from them they've got great
accessories too but speaking of drinks
next up from drink lemon kind calm I've
got there one day cleanse they also have
a 3 day cleanse but this one day cleanse
is something that I personally use
before I go on air or before I'm going
out to the beach the day before I'm
invited to a party and I just want my
dress to fit a little bit different so
what really makes these drinks different
than anything else out there is that
they're shelf stable so they've got a
great mango peppermint green tea and
aronia berry lemonade they've got
fabulous flavors that I'm loving you can
even add them to any of your own cup of
ice at home and again it's gonna really
just help you purify and to bloat your
system you start them at 7:00 in the
morning till 9:00 o'clock at night so
you're drinking every two hours so
you're not gonna feel hungry but this is
kind of my must and the one day cleanse
goes for under 50 bucks so add that to
your shopping list next we all want to
look like all the celebrities on Dancing
with the Stars with their beautiful
glows they actually use South Seas to
get that beautiful glow I love to start
off with their package of they've got my
prep my tan
I extend and their extender I've
actually personally been using for over
a decade I love it to help keep my tan
but the real real secret sauce is their
Tahitian tan mist which I like to say is
my spray tan in a bottle you'll
basically hold it around 12 inches away
less is more a little bit goes a long
way
there's no stickiness no funky odors and
it dries immediately another huge huge
factor I know Hannah brown even from
Dancing with the Stars is a huge huge
fan of this product and again I really
love it and it works on all skin tones
and lastly we all care about being safe
opening doors at this time of year doing
anything or not touching anything
so from clean fob calm I've got there
hundred-percent antimicrobial clean fob
so this little key that they have can go
inside your wallet it can open up any
cans that you may have and he drinks
that you may have out by the pool any
bottles that you have you can put it on
your keychain it goes with you anywhere
it'll open doors it'll open up you can
use the tip of it to do any types of
things for screwdrivers you can use it
on your cell phone
ATM machines or carrying your shopping
bags so again they even have really
great deals right now on a family pack
so check out their website and again you
just add it to your keyring all these
are great products add to your summer
shopping list